we are seeing a booming
american economy whether it's the jobs
market the the dow as you see on your
screen there continues to hit record
highs you've got wages moving higher so
why
is it that this administration wants to
spend all this money when it seems
things are getting better the questions
are piling up for president biden
who now becomes the first president and
a century to not hold a solo press
conference
43 days into his term
no biden alone
at the lectern in the white house it
took president trump 28 days to face
reporters while president obama took
questions in 21 and president george w
bush 34. since the summit
though
by all honest accounts
was sadly and i do not say this with
glee it was sadly an abject failure by
the biden administration how do we
recover from this folks outside of
georgia and outside of other the highly
contested states saying look at these
numbers uh joe biden got 12 million more
votes than barack obama on barack
obama's best election i mean how is that
possible he spent the whole the whole
campaign bunkered down in his basement
uh not saying much at all uh the
president has had enormous successes
with the economy with operation warp
speed etc how could he have done 12
million more votes than barack obama
that's that's really the overall writing
question in most people's minds i really
would hope that fox would really look at
what happened in this election and how
we can because every social studies
teacher is wrestling with this discerns
back from fiction we have to do that so
what social media yeah we have
well we have a president president biden
uh was elected in 2020 i i think that
all of that is is quite clear um so i
i'm not sure why you you know are so
concerned with with that part with that
particular moment in history every
election is significant nobody is hiding
anything under any rocks here our
country's got to come together and joe
biden said yesterday i want unity he
talked about that in his speech but the
first thing he does the first order of
business is to walk in sit down at the
table and he has 17 executive orders
really wiping away much of what
president trump did so his supporters
are saying how can we have unity if
you're taking away everything that we
like correct
i'm going to answer the question
we all have an obligation and i would
say fox news especially especially fox
news has a particular obligation to make
sure people know the election wasn't
stolen
fox news brad i'm gonna answer your
question fox news needs to make sure
that the americans fox
that the news people brett
you're doing the interview i'm answering
the questions congresswoman in recent
weeks on rare occasions away from his
basement bunker very rare the very weak
the very frail the cognitively
struggling joe vowed to make unity a top
priority and as we speak another massive
migrant caravan from central america is
headed straight to our borders about one
of the most dramatic shifts the next
four years are going to entail is the
biden administration crawling into bed
with china it was it was an odd speech
other than someone who believes deeply
that a socialist vision of america a big
government vision of america is what the
american people want i don't think
that's the case now the entire event
seemed like an ongoing exercise in elder
abuse complete with scam artists like
this time the europeans who spend their
time patronizing the patient all the
while working to drain his bank account
except in this case of elder abuse it's
america's bank account and our
independence that's at risk the estate
tax he will not be including that
campaign plan to raise the estate tax
from 40 to 45
or lower the exemption from 11 million
to 3.5 million because there are a lot
of people particularly family farm
owners who are very concerned about that
particular position if it went in
they would be sunk yeah he he'll get
around to it trust me uh america you
elected bernie sanders you just didn't
know it thursday night it was like
watching a train wreck in slow motion
now despite weeks of preparation even
fake news cnn admits it cheat sheets uh
with 14 point font and of course a
compliant media mob lobbing one softball
question after another
it uh still was not enough for joe biden
the frail the weak the cognitively
struggling clearly commander-in-chief or
is he did not do well today well we can
learn the first thing this is not a
unity group this is a surrendering to
the socialist we see what this america
last agenda is doing to our country the
world sees what an america last agenda
is doing to our country our enemies are
salivating over it they love the fact
that our president is clearly unstable
clearly unwell you can tell from his
performance and his fumbles to meet the
biden renewed deal targets
america has to get this america has to
stop eating meat
stop eating poultry fish seafood eggs
dairy
and animal-based fats okay got that
no burgers on july 4th
no steaks on the barbie i'm sure middle
america is just going to love that
can you grill those brussels sprouts
so get ready you can throw back a
plant-based beer with your grilled
brussels sprouts and wave your american
flag call it july 4th green he's the six
trillion dollar man big government joe
biden is promising an avalanche of new
spending on top of his massive stimulus
plan biden wants to expand the role of
the federal government in just about
every aspect of your life so it's
official the biden's affection is
totally real it's in no way part of a
slick pr campaign devised by cynical
consultants determined to hide the
president's senility by misdirection not
at all their love is as real as climate
change that the highest number is
because biden is sending them in
janine just because you say my number
wrong doesn't mean they're wrong and you
want to talk about about no there are
facts these are the facts
they're not facts i mean very few things
that i hear in the show tonight have
been facts what's their plan well in a
sentence they'd like to make the rest of
america very much like our biggest
cities have become squalid dangerous
chaotic and unhappy they'd like to do to
your neighborhood what they have done to
new york city joe biden scared the hell
out of me tonight he looked weak as
commander in chief and he embraced
socialism
okay well neil he's not saying anything
about how much he's getting paid or if
he has a message for president biden but
he does say that more people are coming
how close are you to getting back in the
room what do you miss most about not
being in school
um i miss most obviously seeing my
friends and all the after school
activities that i've done and i think
that we're very very close getting back
to school
and i think that
um the way that our new president is
handling things is a very good way and
we would not have gone
to this if it were still the last
president really that's hard to believe
because the last president was saying i
want every kid back in school